[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen bei der Fußball-WM feiert
heute vor allem Gastgeber Australien das
Nationalteam der Frauen steht zum ersten
Mal im WM Halbfinale der Kontinent
jubelt gleich mehr dazu schönen guten
Abend und wir schauen auf die
Nachrichten Themen von heute
Kritik an Lindners Sparplänen die
Haushaltskürzungen treffen Familien und
gehen zu Lasten von Renten und
Pflegeversicherung
Rückkehr in ein zerstörtes Paradies nach
den verheerenden Bränden in Hawaii
dürfen erste Bewohner wieder zu ihren
früheren Häusern
und der teuerste Transfer der Bundesliga
ist perfekt Englands Torjäger Harry Kane
wechselt für mehr als 100 Millionen Euro
zum FC Bayern
[Musik]
viele werden im kommenden Jahr den
Sparkurs der Bundesregierung zu spüren
bekommen um die Schuldenbremse
einzuhalten hat der Finanzminister
seinen Kollegen und Kolleginnen enge
finanzielle Grenzen gesetzt jetzt gibt
es dazu einen Gesetzentwurf das
haushaltsfinanzierungsgesetz danach soll
beim Elterngeld gekürzt werden ebenso
die Zuschüsse für Renten und
Pflegeversicherung außerdem steigt der
CO2-Preis das hatte schon die
Vorgängerregierung von Union und SPD auf
den Weg gebracht Frank Buchwald mit
Details
monatelang haben sie gerechnet im
Finanzministerium nun ist klar im
Haushalt für 2024 regierte Rotstift alle
Ministerien müssen sparen damit die
Schuldenbremse greift ein falsches
Signal kritisiert die linke Opposition
wir haben in Deutschland kein
ausgabeproblem wir haben ein
Einnahmeproblem und wir sind eines der
wenigen Länder die keine Vermögenssteuer
haben bzw Erbschaftssteuer wo fette
Erben bzw fette Erbschaften mit einem
ganzen mittleren Steuersatz versehen
sind und das geht überhaupt nicht in
einen solchen Zeiten der Staat spart für
die Bürger wird manches teurer heizen
etwa oder tanken so soll die CO2-Abgabe
von 30 auf 40 € pro Tonne klettern das
war teuer Gas und Öl der Spritpreis
dürfte wohl um 3 Cent pro Liter steigen
Schätze ADAC auch die Zuschüsse zur
rentenpflege und
Arbeitslosenversicherung sollen geringer
ausfallen bei Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgebern Kritik in einer
Stellungnahme der BDA heißt es
wer Aufgaben zu lassen der
Arbeitslosenversicherung verlagert und
Zuschüsse zu Renten und zu sozialen
Pflegeversicherung kürzt spart nichts
sondern Buch lediglich eigene Lasten auf
das Konto der beitragsgemeinschaft um
großer Aufreger auch die geplanten
Kürzungen beim Elterngeld eine
Entscheidung der Familienministerin sie
muss 500 Millionen einsparen
das haben wir als FDP so deutlicher auch
formuliert die zuständige Ministerin
Pauls bleibt bisher bei ihren
Kürzungsvorschlägen wir haben
Alternativen vorgelegt und wir hoffen
dass wir Frau pausi noch überzeugen
können am Mittwoch soll das Kabinett
über die Sparvorschläge beraten wie viel
von ihnen am Ende jedoch Wirklichkeit
wird entscheiden erst im Herbst die
Haushaltsberatungen im Bundestag
nach der Festnahme eines mutmaßlichen
Spions im bundeswehrbeschaffungsamt in
Koblenz strebt Innenministerin Fräser
strengere Sicherheitsprüfungen bei
Behörden an es müsse zum Beispiel
genauer kontrolliert werden wie
Mitarbeiter die in sicherheitskritischen
Bereichen arbeiten mit sozialen Medien
umgehen sagte sie der Rheinischen Post
auch der Schutz vor Sabotage achten
solle verstärkt werden
in der Ukraine sind bei russischen
Luftangriffen laut Behörden mindestens
zwei Menschen getötet worden mehrere
wurden verletzt Russland wiederum meldet
Angriffe auf die krim-brücke die das
russische Festland mit der besetzten
ukrainischen grimmhalbinsel verbindet
Fotos zeigen hohe Rauchsäulen an der für
Russland strategisch wichtigen Brücke
nach russischen Angaben wurden
zahlreiche Raketen abgefangen die Brücke
sei unbeschädigt überprüfen lässt sich
das nicht
gegen den Sohn von US-Präsident beiden
laufen seit Jahren Ermittlungen
Handarbeiten wird etwa
Steuerhinterziehung vorgeworfen und
illegaler Waffen Besitz nun soll ein
Sonderermittler herausfinden was an den
Vorwürfen dran ist politisch sorgt das
für neuen Streit denn die Republikaner
stellen die Unabhängigkeit des
Ermittlers David weiß in Frage der hatte
schon mal mit dem Fall zu tun und sei
damals viel zu großzügig gewesen David
sauer berichtet
der Sohn könnte zum wunden Punkt zu
einer Belastung im anrollenden Wahlkampf
seines Vaters werden es sei im
öffentlichen Interesse die Vorwürfe
transparent aufzuklären sagt der
Justizminister
die Ernennung unterstreicht des
Engagement des Justizministeriums
Unabhängigkeit und Rechenschaftspflicht
zu gewährleisten in einer besonders
sensiblen Angelegenheit
mit dem neuen Status als Sonderermittler
erhält der wird weiß mehr Befugnisse in
den Ermittlungen wegen
Steuerhinterziehung und illegalen
Waffenbesitzes ein Deal zwischen
Handarbeitens Anwälten und der
Staatsanwaltschaft war kürzlich erst
geplatzt ein Verfahren wird jetzt
wahrscheinlicher
die Arbeit des sonderermittlers und die
Negativschlagzeilen geben den
Republikanern die Gelegenheit das Thema
im Wahlkampf möglichst lange gegen Joe
Biden zu verwenden Demokraten hingegen
können auf dem Weg womöglich den Vorwurf
entkräften des Justizministerium sei
politisch nicht unabhängig die
Republikaner versuchen bereits jetzt die
Unabhängigkeit des sonderermittlers in
Zweifel zu ziehen
das ist doch zu 100 Prozent ein
politischer Schachzug wie kann man
jemanden ernennen der vor weniger als
zwei Wochen erst versucht hat ein
günstiges Angebot auszuhandeln
alle fanatischen Trump rechts außen
schreien doch jetzt und sagen es sei
nicht richtig nicht fair nicht gerecht
der ehemalige Präsident Trump versucht
Handarbeiten hier zu benutzen um sein
eigenes Verhalten zu entschuldigen
es ist eine Zeit höchst aufgeladener
politischer Stimmung der
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf für 2024 nimmt
gerade erst Fahrt auf Schlammschlacht
garantiert inklusive
wir bleiben noch in den USA so sieht es
jetzt aus in Lahaina den gerade noch so
beliebten Touristenort auf der
hawaiianischen Insel Maui um sich vor
den Flammen zu retten sind die
Flüchtenden aus den Autos ins Meer
gesprungen es sei nicht rechtzeitig
gewarnt worden heißt es die Zahl der
Toten ist mittlerweile auf 80 gestiegen
wegen giftiger Gase und den
Rettungsarbeiten können die Überlebenden
erst nach und nach zurück alle
Rückkehrer müssen sich auf Zerstörungen
ungekannten Ausmaßes gefasst machen
während der Gouverneur Volker Duce
sie wollen alle schnell zurück die
Menschen in der 12.000 Einwohner Stadt
Lahaina viele haben Angst haben die
Bilder der Zerstörung im Fernsehen
gesehen oder im Internet und wollen
jetzt wissen was heil geblieben ist ein
klammes Gefühl mit ein bisschen Hoffnung
doch bei vielen ist die Enttäuschung
groß
wir haben alles verloren Gott sei Dank
haben wir noch uns alles was wir hatten
ist plötzlich weg
warum sollte ich weggehen das ist meine
Heimat das sind meine Leute wir tun was
wir können um es wieder aufzubauen
das Feuer kam Rasen schnell mit starken
Winden bis zu 130 km pro Stunde im
ganzen Straßen Zügen blieben kaum mehr
als die Grundmauern stehen viele saßen
in ihren Fahrzeugen in der Falle weil
die Kleinstadt nur zwei Ausfallstraßen
hat auf der einen Seite das Meer auf der
anderen Seite das Feuer viele Einwohner
beklagen sie sei nicht rechtzeitig von
den Behörden gewarnt worden
normalerweise machen sie die
hurrikan-sirenen an oder tun etwas um
uns zu wahren da war nichts jeder
evakuiert nur durch Mundpropaganda
US-Fernsehsender berichten inzwischen
staatliche Stellen hätten zugegeben dass
viele Sirenen auf Maui einfach nicht
ausgelöst worden waren es gab zwar
Warnhinweise auf Handys aber viele Netze
brachen offenbar bei den Bränden
zusammen
auch das Wahrzeichen der Stadt den
majestätischen Bananenbaum am Hafen der
Stadt hat das Feuer erfasst er ist 150
Jahre alt einer der ältesten seiner Art
in den Vereinigten Staaten jetzt zwar
stark gezeichnet aber er steht noch für
viele hier ist der ein Zeichen der
Widerstandskraft der Hawaiianer und der
Hoffnung
vor fast genau zwei Jahren eroberten die
Taliban die Macht in Afghanistan zurück
seither warten zehntausende Menschen auf
die versprochene Ausreise nach
Deutschland sie leben in ständiger Angst
vor einer Vergeltung der radikal
islamischen Machthaber
aufnahmeberechtigt hier sind rund 40.000
besonders gefährdete Landsleute und ihre
Familien darunter
24.800 ehemalige ortskräfte
nach Deutschland einreisen konnten
bislang
2.400 davon mit Familienmitgliedern sind
das 11.000 Personen Henriette de
Maizière
der Junge Afghane in Berlin will
unerkannt bleiben sich und seine
Angehörigen nicht in Gefahr bringen er
will uns mit seinem Onkel verbinden
Unterlagen belegen der arbeitete als
ortskraft in Afghanistan für die
deutschen seither lebt er mit seiner
Familie versteckt in Kabul wartet auf
seine Ausreise
wir haben für die Gesellschaft für
internationale Zusammenarbeit gearbeitet
wir haben dafür unsere Leben auf Spiel
gesetzt und jetzt wir sind ärgerlich mit
der deutschen Regierung keine Antwort
auf unsere Fragen niemand kümmert sich
um unsere Probleme
August vor zwei Jahren Flughafen Kabul
überstürzt verlassen die westlichen
Nationen das Land viele Afghanen die den
Terror der Taliban fürchten wollen mit
werden jedoch zurückgelassen auch viele
sogenannte ortskräfte tausende warten
bis heute darauf aus dem Land zu kommen
sowohl das Außen als auch das
Innenministerium wollen dazu kein
Interview geben
dass Deutschland stärker als andere
Länder wenn es im Zweifel zwischen
Bürokratie und Humanität geht sich also
auch für die Bürokratie entscheidend und
ist damit Menschen schwer macht und das
ist nicht erfreulich und das gehört zu
den Dingen die aufzuarbeiten haben
Deutschland müssen Worst Case Szenarien
auch für andere Krisenregionen wie Mali
den Sudan oder Niger entwerfen so der
Appell heute auf dem Ort Kräfte Kongress
in Berlin
das muss in Friedenszeiten muss man sich
überlegen wie gehen wir in der Krise
auch mit unseren eigenen Angestellten um
und es ist nicht vielleicht sinnvoll die
vielleicht zumindest aus der
Gefahrenzone irgendwie zu unterstützen
dass sie fliegen können es brauche ein
Konzept für den schutzlokaler
Beschäftigter zumindestens das sollte
die Lehrer aus Afghanistan sein
dramatisch bleibt die Lage auch auf den
verschiedenen Fluchtrouten im Ärmelkanal
starben am Morgen mindestens sechs
Menschen darunter auch Afghanen sie
hatten versucht von der französischen
Küste nach Großbritannien zu gelangen
mehrere Bootsinsassen werden noch
vermisst 49 konnten gerettet werden
besonders viele Menschen wagen derzeit
auch die Überfahrt von Nordafrika über
das Mittelmeer nach Europa oft in See
untüchtigen völlig überladenen boten
allein das Rettungsschiff Ocean Viking
brachte in 48 Stunden mehr als 620
Personen in Sicherheit
nach Deutschland nicht mehr mit Öl und
Gas heizen sondern mit erneuerbaren
Energien das ist das Ziel der wärmewende
Biogas zum Beispiel ist flexibler als
Sonne und Windkraft in Deutschland gibt
es mittlerweile rund 10.000
Biogasanlagen sie produzieren
ausreichend Wärme für gut 2,5 Millionen
Haushalte jetzt ist einer der größten
Händler Europas insolvent bmp-
das Biogas in diesen Rohren soll
eigentlich die wärmewende in
Garmisch-Partenkirchen problemlos
sichern eigentlich stattdessen gibt es
hier seit Monaten Krisengespräche bei
den Gemeindewerken der Grund ihr
biogashändler BMP Greengas ist Insolvenz
das Unternehmen bietet Stadtwerken
bundesweit nun an weniger zu liefern für
deutlich mehr kosten also sowas gab es
noch nie wir waren zunächst erstmal ein
bisschen geschockt und auch gelähmt wir
wollten auch unsere Fernwärme im Ort
massiv ausbauen jetzt wegen der
wärmewende die angekündigt ist das ist
alles jetzt in der Schule der Verband
der kommunalen Unternehmen beziffert den
Gesamtschaden auf rund 150 Millionen
Euro bei Stadtwerken in ganz Deutschland
BMW begründet die eigenen Pleite mit der
Energiekrise tatsächlich soll der
Händler langfristige Verträge mit seinen
Kunden abgeschlossen haben schon Jahre
vor dem Krieg in der Ukraine selbst habe
das Unternehmen das Gas bei Produzenten
kurzfristig eingekauft nicht unüblich
allerdings war BMP offenbar nicht genug
gegen Krisen abgesichert in der Branche
nur BNP unternehmen können
beispielsweise Teil eines größeren
Unternehmens sein was im Zweifel zum
Beispiel Kapital zuschiesst gibt aber
auch die Möglichkeit sich über
sogenannte Versicherung quasi
abzusichern die Absicherung bei BMP
sollte der Mutterkonzern EnBW sein der
wiederum zu großen Teilen dem Land
Baden-Württemberg gehört das Land
schweigt der Energiekonzern antwortet
schriftlich die EnBW hat jederzeit zu
ihrer Verantwortung gestanden und sich
mit einem signifikanten dreistelligen
Millionenbetrag engagiert in Garmisch
und über allem Bundesgebiet könnten am
Ende die Kundinnen die Kosten stemmen
müssen doch der Druck auf die EnBW und
auch die Landesregierung in Stuttgart er
könnte steigen
wir steuern ungebremst auf die nächste
Katastrophe zu so drastisch warnt
Florian Hoffmann von der deutschen
Vereinigung für intensiv und
Notfallmedizin schon jetzt seien viele
Kinderkliniken überlastet käme im Winter
wieder eine Infektionswelle treffe das
die Intensivstationen hart Barbara luke
hat in der Klinik des Arztes erlebt was
Kindern Eltern und dem Klinikpersonal
schon jetzt abverlangt wird
ein stiller Moment im Klinik Trubel
Berührung Zuspruch Pflegerin Christina
versucht sich Zeit zu nehmen für den
schwerkranken jungen dabei ist die
Station gerade wieder unterbesetzt wie
fast immer dann hat man natürlich nicht
die Zeit und die Hände die sich um die
Patienten kümmern können da muss halt
das notwendige gemacht werden dieser
kleine Moment spiegelt das große Drama
der Kinderkliniken in Deutschland Pflege
Notstand zu wenig Betten Notfälle die
abgelehnt werden müssen es ist ein
tägliches jonglieren
morgen Besprechung im haunerschen
Kinderspital in München die Situation
ist dramatisch weil Kinder Medizin eben
anders funktioniert zeitintensiver ist
und deshalb chronischdefizitär ist nicht
abgebildet dass Kinder eben viel viel
mehr Fürsorge brauchen dass alle
Leistungen die Blutentnahmen enger
brauchen und das wäre auch noch Eltern
mit betreuen was der Notstand bedeutet
musste sie mit ihrer Tochter gerade
erleben Mali hatte eine Erdnuss
verschluckt dann die Odyssee drei
Kliniken kein Personal per Helikopter
schließlich hierher am Ende kommen Worte
dafür war die Hölle auf Erden würde ich
sagen also
die schlimmste Nacht nebenan der nächste
Notfall ein bewusstloser Junge ist alt
Personal muss aus einer laufenden OP
abgezogen werden keine Ressourcen Alltag
und die Sorge vor Virus und Grippewellen
wächst jetzt haben wir eben dann den
Herbst und die neue Infektionswelle vor
uns und das bedeutet eben dass wir
wieder dramatisch mehr Patienten haben
und diese Patienten kommen einfach in
die Notaufnahme die kommen vom
Rettungsdienst einfach reingefahren egal
ob der Platz haben oder nicht und bis
die krankenhausreform bei den
Kinderkliniken greift wird noch viel
wertvolle Zeit vergehen
tja jetzt Fußball Rudi bei der WM gab es
heute viele Tränen aber auch großen
Jubel ja für England zum Beispiel ist
ins Halbfinale der Fußball-WM der Frauen
eingezogen die aktuellen
Europameisterinnen besiegten Kolumbien
mit zwei zu eins im Spiel davor hatten
sich die Gastgeberinnen aus Australien
in einem Elfmeter Krimi sieben zu sechs
gegen Frankreich durchgesetzt und
erreichten erstmals überhaupt ein WM
Halbfinale
Down Under ist oben auf die
Australierinnen genannt Mathildas lassen
50.000 im Stadion von brisban jubeln
beim längsten Elfmeterschießen der
wm-historie beim Stand von 6 zu 6 tritt
Wiki bechow für Frankreich an trifft
aber nur das Aluminium
Australiens Coach Toni Gustavsson mahnt
zur Konzentration
Courtney Wein Schütze Nummer 20 könnte
das Spiel entscheiden und tut es auch
die 25-Jährige Stürmerin wird zur
matchwinnerin
ich habe dem Team gesagt nicht die
Medaille um euren Hals zählt sondern das
Herz was von hinten gegen die Medaille
schlägt Herzen die heute im Team und
diesem Land geschlagen haben unglaublich
im Halbfinale treffen die Mathildas auf
England das deutschland-schreck
Kolumbien 2:1 besiegt in Führung
zunächst Kolumbien Lacey Santos 1:0 doch
ein Patzer von Torhüterin Katalina Perez
führt kurz vor der Pause zum Ausgleich
durch lorem dieser Treffer von Alessio
Russo entscheidet schließlich das Spiel
auch die Europameisterinnen können
weiterhin vom WM-Titel träumen
und der DFB-Pokal der Männer hat seine
erste größere Sensation Victoria Köln
aus der dritten Liga gewinnt mit 3:2
gegen Werder Bremen und wirft den
Bundesligisten in der ersten Runde raus
in den anderen Nachmittagsspielen
setzten sich die Favoriten durch Hertha
siegt bei Carl Zeiss Jena mit 5:0
Stuttgart 4:0 in Balingen Gütersloh
unterliegt Holstein Kiel mit
0:25 zu 0 auch für St Pauli bei
Delmenhorst Teutonia Ottensen chancenlos
gegen Bayer Leverkusen 08 FC
ober-neuland aus der Bremen-Liga
verliert 1:9 gegen Zweitligist Nürnberg
Borussia Dortmund souverän bei Schott
Mainz aus der Regionalliga 6:1 und
Dortmund Trainer Edin Terzic ist heute
Abend zu Gast im Aktuellen Sportstudio
ab 23 Uhr und der zweifache Torschütze
von Viktoria Köln gegen Bremen David
Philipp
ja mit dem Wechsel von Harry Kane zu
Bayern München hat die Bundesliga eine
neue Dimension erreicht England
Teamkapitän wurde für vier Jahre
verpflichtet mehr als 100 Millionen Euro
lassen sich die Münchner den
spektakulären Wechsel Kosten
die Erleichterung in München war nicht
nur beim Vorstandsvorsitzenden Jan
Christian Dresen offenkundig Bayern
München ist einer der größten Clubs in
der Welt und ich wollte in meiner
Karriere immer weiterkommen und das
Beste aus mir machen
für den 30-Jährigen Kane der von
Kindesbeinen an bei Tottenham Hotspur
spielte ist es der erste Vereinswechsel
in seiner langen Karriere
mit 58 Toren in 84 spielen darunter auch
das 2:0 bei der EM 2021 im Achtelfinale
gegen Deutschland ist der englische
Teamkapitän Rekordtorschütze der Three
Lions
mit Superstar Harry Kane wollen die
Münchner nun auch international wieder
größere Präsenz zeigen
wir sind gespannt auf seine ersten Tore
Barbara ja und ich habe gehört der hat
sich auch sehr emotional von seinem
verabschiedet ne ja wir werden sehen
jetzt noch einen Blick in den
Nachthimmel auf den
Sternschnuppenstrom der Perseiden
für dieses Schauspiel machen nicht nur
astrophans schon mal die Nacht zum Tage
wie hier in Sachsen-Anhalt ihren Namen
verdanken die sommerstern Schnucken dem
Sternbild
Höhepunkt ist heute Nacht bis zu 60
Sternschnuppen in einer Stunde am besten
zu sehen sind sie an einem dunklen Platz
bei klarem Nachthimmel
und mit Brille auf jeden Fall zwischen
den Wolken könnte ein Blick zu erhaschen
sein sagt Christa Orben ansonsten bleibt
es wechselhaft Viertel vor elf begrüßt
Sie Marietta Slomka im heute-journal
danke für Ihr Interesse ein schönes
Wochenende noch und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend dank tief
Arend wir sehen hier seine große Wolken
Spirale ist es bei uns jetzt zwar
sommerlich warm aber auch schwül denn
das Tief transportiert aus Südwesten die
heiße und eben auch feuchte Luft zu uns
und das bedeutet für uns Wolken und auch
teils schwere Gewitter die sind jetzt
aktuell unter diesen Wolken im Süden und
im Osten des Landes unterwegs kommen in
den nächsten Stunden auch noch ostwärts
voran ab Mitternacht beruhigt sich dann
die Lage und dann können wir zwischen
den Wolken auch mal einen Blick auf die
Sternschnuppen der Perseiden die Nacht
dazu ist recht mild die Werte sinken auf
19 Grad im Breisgau und 13 Grad im
Sauerland morgen erreichen wir im
Südosten dann 27 bis 31 Grad im Passauer
Raum im Nordwesten das ist weniger warm
mit 21 bis 25 Grad dazu gibt es im
Norden und in der Mitte viele Wolken
aber es ist auch Sonne mit dabei und es
gibt nur vereinzelt Schauer zum Beispiel
Nachmittag Lachs zwischen der Ems und
der Nordsee im Süden da ist mehr los
schon in der Früh greifen aus Frankreich
Schauer und Gewitter über die gibt es
dann vermehrt nachmittags zwischen
meinen und Donau aber auch südlich davon
dann sind örtlich Unwetter vor allem mit
Starkregen aber auch mit Hagel und
orkanartigen Böden dabei und in der
neuen Wache geht es auch mit schauen und
Gewittern weiter denn es bleibt
wechselhaft und schwül warm bis heiß